I think there are four areas in which
people make mistakes on applying to the
University of Oxford the first one is
not applying now it's the only sure way
they are not going to get into the
university is if you don't send an
application in so if you think you've
got the academic merit and potential to
get into university and still well here
you must send an application the second
mistake is not practicing for the
admissions tests admissions tests might
kind of surprise lots of you but many
courses at Oxford have admissions tests
the reason is we have admissions testers
so that we have a level playing field
when looking at candidates their tests
that the university is set and it means
that we're looking at everybody the same
set of data in the same way that you
wouldn't sit your driving test your
a-levels or your GCC's without at least
considering how long it's going to take
you to set the paper to go through some
model answers and to see what style of
answer you should be submitting you
really shouldn't be sitting the
admissions test up doing a dry run
before and even if that's just at home
doing the answers yourself and then
looking through the the mark schemes
make sure you get on to the website and
try and find some previous pass papers
just to test them through before you
come up and sit the admissions tests in
November third mistake is what I'd call
not taking risks now this is a personal
application whether it's the personal
statement or the interview which is face
to face this is about things that
interest you now it's really good if you
can apply things to the course you be
studying at Oxford but there's no danger
in looking around as a subject it's
called wider reading don't worry about
delving into work that's slightly away
from the courses that you studied in
school but sort of touch some courses
might be doing that Oxford if you were
to get into the University you will be
studying a range of things around your
subject it's it's really important that
if you find something interesting and
you think it's slightly risky as long as
you're confident in following it through
do take that risk because it will pay
off in some ways for pharoah that people
make in their applications is being
scared of saying I don't know in the
interview now you mustn't use it too
much obviously oh it's better to have a
baseline knowledge of the tasks but you
must remember that the odds
view is not a knowledge test is about
thought processes so instead of saying I
don't know cold-cut if you add the word
but and relate to something that you do
know you're able to thank God the
cheaters through your put your thought
processes your being honest and upfront
without throwing in a load of rubbish
about something that you you vaguely
know about and actually just to see to
put something into the mix that will
guide you through the next part of the
process in whichever problem you might
be solving as part of the Oxford
interview so those are four common
mistakes that people make when applying
to Oxford not applying not practicing
the admissions tests not taking risks
I'm remembering it saying I don't know
is legitimate as long as you can take it
on to the next step of the interview
thank you so much to Dan for agreeing to
be interviewed if you'd like to check
out more videos about Oxford and
Cambridge admissions then check out the
playlist that's on the screen now and
linked in the description below also
take a look at the social media links in
the description for sant Peter's College
which is my old college there are links
to Facebook Twitter snapchat and
Instagram where you can see a snapshot
of student life at an Oxford College